hello there reject nation I'm correct
time John
happy Monday we are the first ones to
cover this Aladdin special look that has
the genie reveal no one else on YouTube
has covered it Wow we are on top of
things this morning early to the party
oh yeah let's
this video has 25k dislikes in 23 K
that's encouraging to pander to popular
opinion and just hate it is already that
way we got to do it with like let's not
give our honest take on it I'm never oh
no yeah I just try to say whatever the
majority are saying listen before we hop
in at that I wanted to say thank you to
all you kids you teenagers and elderly
no one in between who is following us on
the Stardust app 30 second reaction
reviews refills TV shows trailers
sometimes micro sketches post daily over
there
we're probably gonna post about this
stuff afterwards so follow us today free
download pretty used kind of nervous I
made sure to avoid the internet since I
heard this was out but I couldn't cover
this yesterday so I was like it's got a
void the internet yeah
hate this already huh now let's see the
decimation giving like desert
[Music]
I really could have played him better
[Music]
cool hey
Wow
[Music]
is that with Todd trot
we are filming cats I will kill you in
front of everyone you see what you see
what happens soon Apogee whap well you
don't feed my cats properly when I leave
you under and I try to do I try to make
you do favors for me
you don't favor be properly I may be the
can of cat food house we try to nail the
big trailers at one take and now we are
messing this up now when all I want to
do is crap on the CGI ladder
yeah you know it's a little uncanny
valley John take it away I'll be right
back
uh yeah that whole moment gotta say I
wanted there's so much to appreciate
about like the lead up to that and I was
kind of taken aback when I actually saw
it like I feel like I owe it may be
another chance because this is a small
screen and all but like I was I was
there going like this I'm like this is
probably gonna be one of those things
where my god this this probably ain't
really as bad as people are making it
out to be
suppose my god did you leave the top
part of the cat food out we were trying
to give a trailer review here John this
is so unprofessional I don't remember
what the last thing he said was try and
stall until you're back basically I
didn't think it would be as bad as
people were making it out to be based
off the dislikes I haven't read any
comments or people have said about it
yet but I was assuming okay probably the
gene doesn't look too great people's
eyes silly new thing about this trailer
really I thought oh you get that little
big lavash you get the lava shower you
get the the parade in the city you see
Roger that's it see Jasmine in this
trailer is plenty of new thing every and
everything leading up to the Genevra
video is really cool I like the the
effect design of like not CGI stuff with
the parade looks really cool look very
vibrant and colorful
then you know you got the t's what I'm
assuming is the moment where aladdin and
Jasmine are about to go on a magic
carpet ride it's just when you see the
genie and this is using all the stuff
you want to see no dig on is not a dig
on Will Smith's performance because
there's nothing to really go off of
there yeah and you could give it the
benefit of the doubt that hey maybe the
CGI isn't complete yet however that
looks like so first off it looks like
super green-screen
oh it looks like he's in front of a
green screen he looks like composed out
right yeah natural rather than looking
fantastical at least in this one shot No
and it's kind of fascinating the way one
shot can ruin the response to a trailer
like this because up until that point
everything was like I don't get what
people are disliking about this yeah I
love the look of the like you know
Bollywood style you know costumes and
what looks like the dance numbers and
stuff like that and the ensemble pieces
like that stuff looks amazing and they
are great at translating those things in
these live-action adaptations but I you
know you got to say with in terms of
oftentimes that's the excuses like maybe
in terms of the context of it for
example we saw Ali to battle angel
recently and I remember when the
trailers first came out that the biggest
complaint was about her eyeballs and
then I watched the movie and within the
context of the movie it's not
distracting it's not bad it works
perfectly for the film you used to it
then you get like a Steppenwolf thing
with justice league where you're like
maybe the context of the film no it
doesn't really do it's as bad CGI and
here I'm worried I'm having a hard time
going I don't see how the context would
make this look exactly better because of
the fact that it looks green screened on
it doesn't look yeah that's a role at
all it looks unnatural and that's the
thing I kind of worry about with a Guy
Ritchie Aladdin movie anyway is like is
this gonna be kind of over bloated with
bells and whistles and and with the
genie you kind of have to do I guess
special effects and stuff so I'm not
begrudging that really that's more
toward like that big lavash well they
could have practical affected Will Smith
has the genie in that you see like
mistake in the x-men movies is all blue
or
crawler why didn't you just do makeup
further the genie here because this
clearly looks like a CGI blue guy right
here figure out why it looks so CGI you
know like it looks like they've doctor
like was he not bulky enough when they
shot this with him or was he like yeah I
know like that's why I'm kind of
confused that it looks this way because
I don't feel like his face and like
certain areas and it looks like they
tried compensating by making the
lighting like super dark that way well
maybe if we make it really dark in his
shot it'll look more natural but it
doesn't it doesn't I don't hate the
trailer because of this is one moment
but this is the big reveal moment we've
all been leading up to the teaser came
out with like winners Will Smith that's
what we all want to see we want to see
the leap we want to see his
interpretation of the genie and the fact
that they only gave us this like a
couple of seconds to work off of here's
a moment it's just no boy no no baby no
way no for them because I'm sure that
they were like nah this is gonna be the
big moment yeah one's gonna lose their
minds over this and then we have it
seems like in the wrong it feels stiff
and strange but everything everything
else looks fine to me that's the picture
see we got to the lava stuff before
everything falls apart I flashback to
the Sega Genesis game where you can play
with the love of flashback to that
moment so that made me happy borrowed
directly from from the gas money went in
the car - it is get tweets about my
sarcastic comments sometimes now they're
all true what do you talk they're all
true and sarcastic comments everybody
else looks fine it's like they I think
Disney will obviously take notes and do
what they can to improve this because
this phone comes out and I forget when
and what is May 24 but they also said
that there's a lot of the movie where
he's not supposed to be blue like though
the shots have been released this is
like human form to blend in so perhaps
in those sequences it won't you know
like maybe he's not like this the
majority of the film cuz he's like this
the majority of the film that's gonna be
a major problem but if he isn't then who
knows and maybe within context it's fine
I said a hard time envisioning that yeah
I mean at the end of the day this is
still only a minute long teaser that
really only adds a couple things to the
teaser we got before like half of this
trailer is the same just like expanded
yeah but on the Cave of Wonders all that
stuff so and I love Will Smith I do I
think I love Will Smith and I feel like
his performance will be fine you know
I'm not gonna I'm gonna try to go in it
not even though everything looks like
the cartoon I'm gonna try not to compare
it to Robin Williams interpretation
because the only thing Will Smith can do
is do his own thing
so I'm gonna just throw everything out
the window just try taking on some
America's I really do love the performer
I love YouTube him to replace what Robin
Williams did but like hey if anybody's
gonna play the genie he's got that kind
of gregarious boisterous and right areas
Greg Greg yeah Gregory energy that Greg
Alba energy that the Genii role really
needs yeah yeah I think you should play
the genie not a Latin don't sell
yourself short
appreciate that dogs and I'll be a boo
or the carpet
I had walk all over it thanks to I knew
many Disney things my feet on you
alright guys well are you on the up boat
side with the down both sides it's a lot
in trailer I had no idea and so I pulled
this up about the votes and Davos you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
please click that notification now and
download files on the Stardust at
getting jiggy with it no no no nothing